SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION. COOPER ROLL CALL
PLEASED AT W. QUORUM COOPER
HERE.
GROW AND HAVE AIR.
TO HEAR CHOI.
OBERNOLTE HERE.
WE FORTY ONE ITEMS ON THE BULLY
CALENDAR.
FOR ITEMS ONE THROUGH SIX
EIGHT THROUGH TEN.
FOURTEEN THROUGH FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN TO NINETEEN.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY
NINE. THIRTY TWO AND THIRTY FOUR
THROUGH FORTY. SEVEN MOTION
PLEASE.
ROLL CALL.
COOPER I.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
CHOI OBERNOLTE.
NEXT ITEMS SEVEN ELEVEN TO
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN TWENTY. TWENTY
THREE THROUGH TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY ONE
MOTION PLEASE.
LOCAL POLICE.
COOPER I HAVE ERA.
CHIU.
CHOI OBERNOLTE.
ITEM TWENTY ONE FELLOWSHIP
PLEASE.
LOCAL POLICE.
COOPER I HAVE RARE.
CHIU.
OBERNOLTE.
OTHER THIRD THIRTY AYE MOTION
PLEASE.
LOCAL POLICE COOPER AYE
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
OBERNOLTE BY.
ITEM THIRTY THREE PROMOTION
PLEASE.
REPUBLIC.
THANK.
COOPER I HAVE ARROW.
CHIU.
OBERNOLTE.
ITEM FORTY ONE PUSH PLEASE.
LOCAL POLICE COOPER I HAVE RARE.
CHIU.
OBERNOLTE.
THE BIGGEST THE END OF OUR
LITTLE ENCOUNTER THE NEXT MOVE
ON TO.
.
PARDON.
YEAH WE WE HAVE A VOTE CHANGE
PLEASE.
MORE ON ITEM ON VOTE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR.
ONLY TAKES.
DO WE KNOW THANK YOU.
CARE WONDER FIRST ITEM.
.
PALM OF HOUSING COMMITTEE BILL
MEANT ISSUE NUMBER ONE
HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS SIMPLY HOMELESSNESS
PLAN.
THE PLAN WILL.
ALL OF OUR AUDIENCE GET OUT OF
HERE
THIS IS SIMPLY SIMPLY
HOMELESSNESS PLAN. THE PLAN
FOCUSES ON EMERGENCY AID FOR
CITIES.
WE KNOW THIS FUNDING IS NOT A
SOLUTION BUT RATHER. IS A BRIDGE
TO LONG TERM EFFORTS CHAMPION BY
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS LAST YEAR.
INCLUDING ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU.
THE FUNDING CAN BE USED FOR
EMERGENCY INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS
BRIDGE SHELTERS VOUCHERS.
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION AND
RAPID RE HOUSING.
IT'S BEEN PROVEN TO LEAD THE
PERMANENTLY EXITS FROM
HOMELESSNESS.
PROPOSAL INCREASES FUNDING FOR
CAL WORKS HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM BY REMOVING REQUIREMENT.
THAT HE SIXTEEN DAYS OF HOME
ASSISTANCE BE CONSECUTIVE. WHICH
WILL HELP FAMILIES EXPERIENCE
MORE THAN ONE INSTANCE OF
HOUSING INSTABILITY
HOMELESSNESS.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSAL
DEDICATES ONE POSITION FOR THE
HOMELESS COUNSEL TO HOMELESS
YOUTH.
FINALLY PROPOSAL MAKE CHANGES TO
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
IT'S PLAIN OLD FIELD MEMBER
COMMENTS.
OR QUESTIONS.
NOW.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
I MISTER CHAIR COULD I ASK THAT
WE SPLIT OFF THE CAL WORKS
CONSECUTIVE DAY BUDGET REQUEST.
FROM THE VOTE ON THE ENTIRE
PACKAGE.
SURE.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU A MISTER CHAIR AND LET
ME THANK THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN
THE BUDGET CHAIR AND ARE
COLLEAGUES FOR.
PRIORITIZING SPENDING AROUND
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. FROM
THERE ARE NUMBER OF ELEMENTS OF
WHAT'S BEEN PROPOSED THAT I
APPRECIATE AND THEIR COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS THAT I'M HOPING. AS
WE GO THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO EMPHASIZE
ON THE ASSEMBLY AND. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM.
THROUGH S. B. TWO FUNDS ALSO
APPRECIATE.
INCLUDING ELEMENTS OF OF MY AB
THIRTY SEVENTY TWO SO THAT WE
CAN SQUEEZE OUT MORE FUNDING
THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDIT. AYE AND.
AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE BUDGET
YEARS BILL TO PRIORITIZE A ONE
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS OF
SURPLUS FUNDS FOR HOMELESSNESS I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE. ALL THAT
BEING IN THIS PROPOSAL.
THAT BEING SAID.
I THINK THEY'RE A LOT OF
ELEMENTS OF WHAT THE SENATE HAS
PROPOSED IN THIS AREA THAT I
APPRECIATE AND I WANT TO.
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS AT
FIRST I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO HAVE AS SIGNIFICANT AN
EMPHASIS AS WE CAN ON PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING ON
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
I WE KNOW THE PRINCIPLE OF
HOUSING IS THE BEST WAY TO
ADDRESS CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AND
I APPRECIATE. THE BALANCING THE
PRIORITIES THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS BUT I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
TO FOCUS ON I THINK
ADDITIONALLY.
ENSURING THAT ANY MONIES THAT GO
TO.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT WE
HAVE APPROPRIATE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AND THAT WE REQUIRE A
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT RECEIVE THESE
FUNDS. ARE TO HAVE PLANS FOR HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO USE THE MONEY
ARE ONE EMPHASIZE THAT.
I ALSO A VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THE SENATE'S PRIORITY OF THE
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM WHICH WAS AND ASSEMBLY
BILL OUT WHEN THIS PAST THIS
PAST YEAR I DO HOPE THAT WE CAN.
BRING UP THE FUNDING LEVELS OUT
TO WHAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED IN THE
SENATE. AND.
THE LAST.
THE EXCESS RAINY DAY FUNDS ARE
THAT I THINK THE ASSEMBLY WE
SHOULD JOIN THE SENATE AND
PRIORITIZING THOSE FUNDS FOR
HOUSING AND FOR HOMELESSNESS.
OUT SO I DO HOPE THERE SOME
CONSIDERATION OF THAT MOVIE TO
THE PROCESS BUT THAT BEING SAID
IDO SUPPORT THIS ARE HAPPY TO
SEE MOVE FORWARD. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
STAND FOR THE PRINCIPLE AT THIS
MOMENT THAT IN THE MIDST OF THE
WORST HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
WERE WILLING TO PUT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
SURPLUS TOWARD THAT END AND
SPEND THOSE FUNDS IN SMART WAYS.
BUT YOU.
IF IT COMES FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GOING UP NO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THIS ITEM.
WE FED PELHAM SNIFFING
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE BEFORE
SO. I'M AS. CAUTION THE SPEAKERS
ME VERY BRIEF IN YOUR
PRESENTATIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TRIM AMBER'S
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU
HAVE ON. A PROVIDED HERE TODAY
THIS IS AN GOING TO
SIGNIFICANTLY YOU KNOW HELP AND
OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF HOMELESSNESS OR FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THAT IS.
AT FIFTY TWO THOUSAND COMPARED
TO THE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND STATEWIDE.
WE WOULD LIKE.
FOR IN THE DISCUSSIONS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AN EQUITABLE
ALLOCATION FORMULA COUNTY HAS
DONE A.
A.
LOT OF WORK ARE READY TO WORK
WITH THE CITIES AND WEEKEND.
GET THE FUNDING TO.
EXPENDED BECAUSE WE HAVE A A
SIGNIFICANT NEED SO WE
DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON MAKING SURE. BECAUSE
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THAN
WHAT I UNDERSTAND TO BE IN THE
SENATE THE.
DISTRIBUTION FORMULA WOULD
ALLOCATE ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT TO
LA COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE ABOUT
OVER FORTY TWO PERCENT OF THE
NEED SO WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU AND
OUR CONCERNS PLEASE IN THOSE TO
STAFF.
YES BUT IF YOU THINK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESTORING OF OR
SOME HEALTH URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A SUPPORTING
CONCEPT ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAYBE
VISION WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE ASSEMBLIES ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS. IN ANDY'S ON
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE CRITICAL I
WOULD WOULD JUST WANNA BE ENSURE
THAT COUNTIES ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION WE PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT ARE NEEDED TO. HELP THE
HOMELESS I'M ON.
OUT OF HOMELESSNESS.
WE WE DO ALL THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES THAT ARE REQUIRED OUT
LIKE AND NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM. OMITTED WHEN I HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS THEY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ON TO THE COMMITTEE.
YOU SPLIT OFF THE SP TWO FUNDS
INTO THE ESG AND THE AB SEVENTY
FOUR I VERY MUCH LIKE AB SEVENTY
FOUR IN THAT PROGRAM HOWEVER
EACH HE HASN'T DONE THE WORK ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT NEW
PROGRAM SO IT'S GONNA TAKE
AWHILE TO GET THAT. UP AND GOING
AND WE WANT THE FUNDS TO BE OUT
AND MOVING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
DESPITE THE HYPE THAT. WAS WHEN
I CONCUR WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND ONE RESPECT THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW HOW THE ALLOCATIONS
ARE GOING TO BE. DONE WITH IT
CITY COUNTY IS IT GOING TO BE
THERE USER CAROL LIKE IN THE
SENATE PROPOSAL IS THAT GONNA BE
THE GOVERNOR'S ISLAND I MAY
REVISE EMERGENCY AID.
ALLOCATIONS WHICH GIVES
DIFFERENT POCKETS SO I JUST
WANNA HIGHLIGHT THOSE ARE
CONCERNS TO THE COMMITTEE BUT WE
FOR MUCH OF SUPPORT SO FOLKS
WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY ON
HOMELESSNESS TWICE SO FAR SO.
IT'S VERY BRIEFLY WEARING
NOTHING NEW RIGHT NOW ALSO.
PLEASE.
YES SIR I'M MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
A SLIGHTLY CALIFORNIA CITIES WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE TO WORK WITH YOU AND FINE
TUNE IT DON'T ALLOCATION PROCESS
THINKING THAT YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREW
AND WE WHICH I'VE NEVER AND WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
WE SUPPORT.
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL ON
HOMELESSNESS EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANSWERING THE CALL
FROM THE BIG ELEVEN MAYORS WE
ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY LA
COUNTY. WE WANT TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFFERS ISSUE GOES
FORWARD ON EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION FORMULA AND JUST
ONE SMALL NOTE.
LOS ANGELES HAS DEDICATED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TOWARDS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
WE WANT TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE ON THE FORM THAT THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT IN EVERY JURISDICTION.
THANKS VALUE.
ON LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT PROVIDING
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO ADDRESS.
THE IMMEDIATE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS BUT WE DO WANT TO ECHO
FROM THE COMMENTS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO MADE THAT. I'VE
SPENDING THOSE FUNDS NEEDS BE
COMPANY BY A CONCRETE PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE RESOURCES
TRANSITION PEOPLE INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING BECAUSE THAT'S TRULY THE
ONLY WAY TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
LONG TERM THANKS. TO YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR THE JOBS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT AND ONE
OF THE DEATHLY AT THE TABLE OF
CONVERSATIONS MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN LANG ON
BEHALF OF MAYOR MARK FARRELL
FROM THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT AND LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
AS THAT COMES TO A CONCLUSION
BEFORE JUNE TWELFTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ESTHER MILLER DAVID JOHNSON HAVE
AMIR DARRELL STEINBERG IN THE
CITY SACRAMENTO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THANK YOU TO THE SUM
OF REPORTING FORCE THIS
PROPOSAL.
BY LIKE THE NUMBER AND SUPPORT
YOUR EFFORTS THANKS THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY PART OF
SUPERVISORS. APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING IN SUPPORT OF
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDING
THROUGH THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
THROUGH THAT YES SHE FORMULA BUT
YOU.
TYRONE BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AT LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND ALSO.
EXPRESS OUR.
HOPEFULNESS THAT THERE IS.
STAFF POSITION DEDICATED TO THE
HOMELESS YOUTH ISSUE WHEN WE
LOST LIKE SEE SOME GRANT FUNDING
SET ASIDE FOR THAT PURPOSE
THINKING THAT YOU.
BRIAN I GUESS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES OF THE COMMENTS OF
WESTERNS AND ANOTHER HOUSING
ADVOCATES AND. MISTER CHU ON THE
POINT ABOUT ENSURING ADEQUATE
INVESTMENT AND LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AS WELL BUT WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INVESTMENT IN
HOMELESSNESS THAT THIS
REPRESENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MARIN HIGGINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AYE ONE ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH THE PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS
AND WESTERN CENTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR KEVIN FAULCONER AND THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND MAYOR TATE
WITH THE CITY OF ANAHEIM WE
THINK YOU STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE IN THIS PROPOSAL WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT IT THANK YOU THE.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF SANTA
ANA AND OAKLAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE WILL WHEN OUR
COMMENTS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER.
BUT YOU.
CAN LARISSA THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND I THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING US OPPOSITION
FOR YEAR BAN PUTTING A SEAT ON
THE COUNCIL FOR A FORMALLY
HOMELESS YOUTH AND. I'M WE
PROVIDING JUST ABSENT
SUGGESTIONS AROUND HOPING ENSURE
THE FUNDING GET DEDICATED
TOWARDS YOU SWAP THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HURST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE COUNTIES OF
RIVERSIDE SANTA CRUZ SANTA CLARA
AND VENTURA. I ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES AND
LOOK FORWARD TO AN ONGOING
DIALOGUE.
BUT YOU.
A GIANT US WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
OVER INFLOWS PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT'S WHAT MY COLLEAGUE A LOT
OF INPUT IN THIS AND A LOT OF
THOUGHTFUL DELIBERATION
CONSIDERATIONS. AND ALSO THINK
STAFF WORKING WITH ALL THE EXTRA
PARTIES.
IT'S BEEN A LONG HAUL THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO DO STILL SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS WE
APPRECIATE IT. THIS POINT WILL
HAVE A VOTE OF THE FIRST TWO
VOTES ACTUALLY THE FIRST VOTE
BEEN HOMELESS PLAN WITHOUT THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM THEIR MOTION.
WELL FIRST THE SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER I HAVE RARE.
CHIU.
CHOI.
OBERNOLTE.
SECOND WHAT WILL BE THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM.
THE MOTION.
REPUBLIC COOPER I HAVE AARON.
CHIU.
CHOI.
OBERNOLTE.
MOTION PASSES THANK YOU.
ONE ITEM NUMBER TWO OFFICE OF
MIGRANTS SERVICES FARM WORKER
HOUSING.
TRULY BILLING WHICH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
INTERROGATIVE ARE GONNA FINANCE.
THIS TRAILER BILL AMENDS
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING THE
LOCATION OF RESIDENTS AND THE
POOL OF OPERATORS FOR OFFICE OF
MIGRANT SERVICES OMS FARMER
HOUSING CENTERS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT OPERATES
TWENTY FOUR OH MESSENGERS TO
PROVIDE SEASONAL LOW COST
HOUSING TO AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
CURRENTLY FAMILIES ARE ONLY
ELIGIBLE TO RESIDE AT NO MESS
CENTER IF THEY HAVE RESIDED
OUTSIDE OF A FIFTY MILE RADIUS
OF THE CENTER FOR THREE OF THE
PRIOR SIX MONTHS.
THIS RULE. AND HE SEES ME
PARENTS MUST RELOCATE THEIR
CHILDREN OUTSIDE OF THE FIFTY
MILE RADIUS IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
WHICH DISRUPTS SCHOOL ATTENDANCE
AND PREVENTS CHILDREN FROM
STAYING WITH YOUR RELATIVES IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE THE YOUR AT
ONE SCHOOL.
THIS TRAILER BILL AMENDS THE
FIFTY MILE RULE TO ONLY APPLY TO
THE HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD RATHER
THAN TO IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN TO REMAIN WITHIN FIFTY
MILES OF THE CENTER WITHOUT
DISQUALIFICATION.
IN ADDITION THE TRAILER BILL
ALLOWS FOR PROPOSALS TO SET
ASIDE UP TO SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE UNITS IN A CENTER FOR
FAMILIES WITH SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF THE
LOCATION OF THEIR RESIDENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES
NOT IMPOSE A BLANKET STATE RIGHT
POLICY BUT RATHER PROVIDES AN
OPTION FOR INDIVIDUAL CENTERS TO
EVALUATE THEIR LOCAL NEEDS.
THE REQUESTED.
REQUIRES.
M. IS USING THEIR PROPOSAL.
WOULD HAVE TO BE PRESENTED TO
THE RESIDENT COUNCIL OF I AM A
GIVEN CENTER AND BE APPROVED BY
EACH CD.
.
IN ADDITION THIS TRAILER BILL AS
PROPOSED ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
TWO CONTRACT WITH FOR PROFIT
PROPERTY UP PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
ENTITIES AND THE ABSENCE OF
WILLING AND ABLE NONPROFIT OUR
PUBLIC ENTITIES.
.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT CANNOT
CONTRACT WITH FOR PROFIT
OPERATORS DESPITE A FREQUENT
LACK OF ENTITIES IN RURAL AREAS.
HOWEVER WE UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
CONCERNS WITH THE SECTION OF THE
TRAILER BILL AND WOULD BE
AMENABLE TO STRIKING THE
SECTION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH YOUR STAFF.
AND CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS IF
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS ADOPTED.
SEVERAL ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED IN
THE TO THE BILL OF BEEN THE
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION BUT I AND
PRIOR DISCUSSIONS BEFORE POLICY
COMMITTEES.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY STAKEHOLDERS AND FOR THAT
REASON LEGISLATION HASN'T MOVED
FORWARD ON SOME OF THESE TOPICS.
AND GIVEN THAT BACKGROUND IT'S
NOT CLEAR WHY THEY SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD AS TRAILER BILL AND NOT
AS CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS BEFORE
THE. THE POLICY COMMITTEES INTO
THE POLICY PROCESS.
THANK YOU COMMISSION COMMITTEE.
JUST A FEW THOUGHTS I CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT.
THAT THIS
PROPOSAL HAS SOME SIGNIFICANT
POLICY IMPACTS.
.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ISSUE I I'M SUPPORTIVE TO IT
MOVING FORWARD BUT.
I ALSO APPRECIATE AND.
AND.
AND RELYING ON THE COMMITMENT.
THAT THE HAVE PROPONENTS OF
THIS WILL BE SITTING DOWN AND
WORKING WITH THE OPPONENTS AS
MEASURE TO HOPEFULLY WORK OUT
THESE ISSUES IF THAT'S NOT
POSSIBLE. IT YOU KNOW I THINK IT
IT IT IS MORE APPROPRIATE
TYPICALLY AND POLICY CONTEXT BUT
GIVEN THE URGENCY GIVEN THE NEED
AND WANT TO SUPPORT THIS MOVING
FORWARD TO OUT TO HOPEFULLY GET
TO THE RIGHT PLACE.
CARRIER.
VERY BRIEFLY I'M I'M WOULD DOES
SUPPORT MOVING IT FORWARD AT
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE. FOR
PROFIT.
AND.
BECAUSE IF YOU WILL.
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
WITH THIS KIND OF A OF A
PROPOSAL IS TO CREATE
FLEXIBILITY AND SO I'M I'M IN
SUPPORT OF IT.
THE MOTION.
OKAY ALOFT.
ALL GOING UP PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
POINT.
HER GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRIAN AGAINST ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE'VE HAD.
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF YOUR
STAFF AND WITH THE GOVERNOR
ABOUT OUR CONCERNS ON THIS
MEASURE.
REMAIN THAT THE PROPOSAL AS
DESCRIBED BY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WOULD TAKE WATER CURRENTLY.
THAT CENTERS THAT ARE RESERVED
FOR MIGRANT HOUSEHOLDS AND ALLOW
THE MAJORITY OF THE U. S. B.
OCCUPIED BY.
NON MIGRATORY HOUSEHOLDS.
LIKE EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM WE
SUPPORT.
AND CLEARLY WANT TO FIND A
RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT. GOOD
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
FOR ALL KIDS BUT PARTICULARLY
FOR THOSE OF MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS WHO HAVE ON SOME OF THE
POOREST EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
WE ALSO HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN
THIS STATE.
I'M ANDREW AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE THOSE
MIGRANT FAMILIES WHO OTHERWISE
DON'T.
HAVE PERMANENT HOUSING IN THE
AREA WHERE THEY'RE WORKING.
THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD AND
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED THESE
MIGRANTS CENTERS WE'RE HOPING
IN.
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT WILL TODAY ARM
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK TO
CRAFT LANGUAGE THAT STRIKES OUT
BALLOTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MARKET CENTERS ARE AVAILABLE.
FOR THAT MATTER FAMILIES WHAT WE
ALSO MEET THE OBJECTIVE OF
KEEPING.
KIDS IN SCHOOL.
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE GET
THERE AS THIS BILL MOVES TO THE
BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SO EMOTIONAL FOR A SECOND
AS WORKING FROM WITH THE LOTION
MACON SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT FOR PROFIT.
FOR PROFIT PLUS.
NUMBER HOPELESS COOPER I HAVE
RARE.
CHIU.
CHOI.
OBERNOLTE.
THREE ONE ON EXPLANATION OVER
THREE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISASTER PLAN ASSISTANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SUSAN GOODISON I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION AND
MANAGEMENT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED A SERIES
OF UNPRECEDENTED NATURAL
DISASTERS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILD FIRES IN THE
COUNTIES OF BUTTE. LAKE
MENDOCINO NAPA NEVADA SOLANO
CINEMA IN CUBA. DESTROYED EIGHTY
NINE HUNDRED STRUCTURES AND
CAUSED FORTY THREE DEATHS.
IN DECEMBER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED THE LARGEST WILDFIRE
IN THE STATE'S HISTORY AND THE
COUNTIES OF LOS ANGELES SAN
BERNARDINO SAN DIEGO. SANTA
BARBARA RIVERSIDE AND VENTURA.
THE MUD SLIDES THAT ON SUIT IN
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTIES WERE AMONG THE MOST
LETHAL IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT REQUEST A
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
STATE OPERATIONS TO ADDRESS THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISASTERS INCLUDING.
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A CONTRACT
TO SUPPORT RECOVERY AND COMPLETE
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENTS IN THE
AFFECTED COUNTIES.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER WORKLOAD TO
IMPLEMENT THE CONTRACT. AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A
CONTRACT TO FACILITATE DISASTER
PLANNING AND LOCAL GENERAL
PLANS.
FINANCE.
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
DOYLE.
THE QUESTION COMMITTEE.
NOT A CHOI.
PUTTING HERE AT ANY YEAH ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE DAMAGES OF WELL
WHAT.
DID I MISS IT.
HI JENNIFER SEGER SYSTEM DEPUTY
DIRECTOR HDD UP.
COURSE COUNTY WAS INCLUDED IN
THAT FIRST INITIAL CONTRACT THAT
WE DID AS PART OF THE. PLAN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES
BECAUSE OF THE TIME MEAN. THEY
WERE HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME
AS THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE SO THEY'RE COVERED IT'S
JUST THE ADDITIONAL DISASTERS
THAT WERE DECLARED POST.
AND DECEMBER.
OF LAST YEAR.
BUT NOT IN THIS ONE.
SO ORANGE COUNTY IS ALREADY
COVERED AS PART OF OUR EXISTING
CONTRACT.
I WOULD HOPE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
ANY WHICH IS BECOMES ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOROTHY JOHNSON
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
APPRECIATE INCLUSION OF
ADDITIONAL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AREAS AND THE OPPORTUNITY MAKES
SURE THAT THE AMOUNTS ALLOCATED
ARCHERD UP AT THE COUNTER PARTY
SO IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
KIDDER CONDITIONS SADAT THE
MAYOR VISION PROPOSAL THEIR
MOTION.
IN A MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER I HAVE AERO.
CHIU.
CHOI.
OBERNOLTE.
YOU'RE WONDERING IF SADDAM ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR INCREASED LEGAL AND
PER.
PROGRAMMATIC WORKFLOW
.
PLEASE SEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TINA
DALY I'M WITH THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES HOUSING
AGENCY.
AND FINANCE.
OF.
NOT ON SORRY TALKED SOFTLY.
IRATE I'M
MONIES TINA DAILY I'M WITH THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
HOUSING AGENCY. AND THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU IS FOUR FOUR
POSITIONS IN FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
INCREASED WORKLOAD AT OUR
AGENCY.
I WERE RELATIVELY NEW AGENCY
WERE FORMED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
REORGANIZATION PLAN.
AND. I WE'VE JUST WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN A BUSY AGENCY BUT WE'VE
SEEN A BIG INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
AND WE'VE HAD A LOT OF NEW
PROGRAMS
COUPLE WILL HAVE YOU KNOW TWO
DEPARTMENTS AS OF JULY FIRST.
WORD ON SETTING UP THAT CANNABIS
A BUREAU AND ALSO THE APPEALS
PANEL.
UNIONS OWN.
HAVE HOUSING STUFF AS YOU HAVE
NOTICED AND SO THIS IS JUST A
REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THAT.
FINANCE.
TIFFANY GARCIA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
GIVEN THE INCREASED WORK BUT WE
HAVE SEEN AT AGENCY. LOL.
HUNTERS TO AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS AND THE QUESTIONS
FOR THE COMMITTEE.
ALTHOUGH NOT NOT PUBLIC COMMENT.
I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE THIS
SPRING FINANCE LETTER MOTION.
LET MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER. I HAVE RARE.
CHIU.
CHOI.
OBERNOLTE.
THE. LAST OF ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
AB ONE NINETY FIVE FIX.
CAROLYN SHE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUT THE ISSUE
BEFORE YOU IS A LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL I SPECIFICALLY IT IS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO SUSPEND
FOR TWO YEARS THE LOCAL BOND
RELATED PROVISIONS IN A. B.. A
ONE NINETY FIVE TO ALLOW TIME
FOR CONCERTS TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THE POLICY PROCESS AND NOT
AFFECT NEAR TERM ELECTIONS.
FINANCE.
TAMARA JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WE HAVE NO POSITION
AT THIS TIME AS WE HAVE NOT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
BUT OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I I
HAVE STRONG FEELINGS ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I WAS THE AUTHOR OF AB
ONE NINETY FIVE SO. JUST TAKE A
MINUTE AND WALKING THROUGH THE
HISTORY OF WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
UP SEVERAL YEARS AGO I AUTHORED
A BILL AB EIGHT OR NINE AT THAT
WHATEVER THAT REQUIRED. A OUT
BALLOT LABELING TRANSPARENCY SO
OF THE FEE FEELING WAS IF
TAXPAYERS GOING TO VOTE FOR A
TAX INCREASE THEY OUGHT TO KNOW
THE GOOD STUFF WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GET FOR THAT MONEY AND
THEY ALL KNOW THE BAD STUFF FOR
THE GONNA HAVE TO PAY FOR IT.
AND THAT'S JUST AN ISSUE OF
BASIC TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS
IN ELECTIONS
SO I THAT BILL. PASSED AND WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AB ONE
NINETY FIVE LAST YEAR EXTENDED
THE PROVISIONS OF THAT BILL TO
BOND ISSUES AND AT THE TIME IT
WAS EXTREMELY UNCONTROVERSIAL.
HOWEVER IN THE MEANTIME.
WE'VE BECOME AWARE OF SOME.
SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE
APPLICATION OF AB ONE NINETY
FIVE DIVINE LIKE WHICH SO I'VE A
BILL THIS YEAR AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT THAT SEEKS TO A
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM.
AND NOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
THROUGH THOSE ISSUES.
.
WE WOULD LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS I'M HIGHLY
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
TO A PLACE WHERE EVERYONE
AGREES.
AND.
IF WE PUT URGENCY ON THAT BILL
OR WE HAVE A VEHICLE IN THE
SENATE THAT WE CAN USE BUT WE
WILL GET WE WILL BE ABLE TO
DELIVER THAT SOLUTION TO. EVERY
BIT AS QUICKLY AS.
.
AS WE GO THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS SO I WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEES.
.
THE COMMITTEES RESPECT AND
FORBEARANCE IN A DELAYING.
TAKING ACTION THROUGH THE
BUDGET ON THIS AND GIVING US A
CHANCE TO US ALL THIS
LEGISLATIVE WEEKS I THINK THAT'S
THE MORE APPROPRIATE WAY OF
DOING IT.
YOU QUESTIONS
ARE GOING UP AND UP PUBLIC
COMMENT ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THE SIDE.
MISTER CHAIR COULD I JUST
CLARIFY I'M I'M WHICH MISTER
EVERETT PULLED. UP HERE ASKING
FOR US TO NOT ADOPT THIS TODAY.
A YES I HAVE LANGUAGE I CAN PASS
IT AROUND THIS IS
OTHER HOT OFF THE PRESS FROM
WHICH COUNSEL THIS IS THE IN IN.
ARE THE RESULT OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I'M I'M HIGHLY
CONFIDENT WE'RE GOING TO GET TO
A PLACE WHERE. WE CAN SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND KEEP EVERYONE AYE
HAPPY SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THE.
IF I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP ON
THAT THOUGH IF THIS MOVES
FORWARD THAT COMMUTERS CAUTION.
LATER IN THE PROCESS RIGHT IF WE
DON'T MOVE IT FOR TODAY THAN WE
DON'T HAVE THE OPTION OF
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION HERE.
YES BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT. YOU KNOW THE STATUS QUO
IS.
IS A LITTLE CUMBERSOME
BUT WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED TODAY
IS TO COMPLETELY EXEMPT BOND
MEASURES FROM ANY KIND OF
DISCLOSURE. ON THE BALLOT LABEL
WHICH I THINK IS A FAR WORSE.
FAR WORSE SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM.
SO SO IS JUST A RECOMMENDATIONS
A TWO YEAR SUSPENSION
NOT TOTALLY DO AWAY WITH IT.
OKAY
IT'S PUBLIC COMMENT NAKED
AFTERNOON STEVE CREWS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE AND SAN
JOSE MAYOR'S OFFICE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND.
MISTER OBERNOLTE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE EFFORTS THAT YOU MADE
THIS YEAR WE HAVE NOT BEEN
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU BUT. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOUR.
LANGUAGE IS MORE LIMITED THAN
WHAT'S PROPOSED JUST IN TERMS
OF.
THERE A FULL BOND EXEMPTION AND
AS THE CHAIR POINTED OUT IT IS A
TEMPORARY BASES AND I KNOW FOR
THE CITY WE'VE SEEN FIRST HAND.
OF THE POLLING WHERE WE'VE SEEN
AS MUCH OF A TWELVE PERCENT
FLIP.
WHEN THE VOTERS.
WERE.
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
INFORMATION AND I UNDERSTAND THE
TRANSPARENCY OF ABOUT
INFORMATION IS REQUIRED IN THE
PAMPHLET.
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN YOU PUT IN
THE SEVENTY FIVE WORD LABEL YOU
OCCUPY NO TWO THIRDS OF THE
SPACE IN YOU'RE LIMITED
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY DESCRIBE
WHAT THE BOND DOES. AND THEN RUN
INTO MECHANICAL ISSUES OF UNDER
ABLE TO TO DETERMINE WHAT BOND
RATES ARE AT A GIVEN TIME
BECAUSE THEY FLUCTUATE. A WHAT
THEY OVER OVER THE LIFE OF THE
BOND SO. THOSE ARE ISSUES OF
CONCERN WE UNDERSTAND THE
TRANSPARENCY WHEN I TRY TO TAKE
AWAY WITH THAT WE THINK THAT.
THE PROPOSAL THAT'S ON THE TABLE
ALLOW FOR THAT PROCESS TO BE
CONSIDERED. AND.
THE FACT IT'S TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS ADDRESSES THE URGENCY OF
ITS I DON'T SEE IT AS A WE HAVE
POTENTIALLY SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS PRETTY
NOVEMBER. AND THAT WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THE.
THIS PROPOSAL COULD BE PASSED
BEFORE THAT'S APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID
JOHNSON HAVE THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
OF SAN JOSE.
THE TWO YEAR TIME OUT WE CAN
WORK ON A LONGER TERM SOLUTION
TO THIS IN THAT INTERIM TIME
SWEET SUPPORT THRILLED AT THIS
POINT.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR THE JOHNSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF A PROPOSAL FOR THE
REASONS MENTIONED AND REALLY THE
URGENCY FOR THE BALLOT MEASURES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY PENDING THIS
YEAR. SO A SOLUTION NOW WE THINK
IS APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS JOINED OF OR SOME
HAVE THEIR PRECARIOUS A
CALIFORNIA.
LISTEN AND HELP ALLEVIATE THE
CONCERNS OF MANY OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SO WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS STILL GIVENS
WITH CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL BY THE
PROPOSED SUSPENSION ALLOWS
GREATER TIME TO WORK ON A
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO.
GAVE WALRATH REPRESENTING
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING AND ALSO LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IN SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
THEY WERE UNABLE TO BE HERE AT
THIS TIME. IN SUPPORT OF THE
LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS RIOS AND
CURRENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
SHORT TERM EFFECTS LOCUM WORK ON
A LONGER TERM FIX IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PETTY WHO ARE
REPRESENTING CRONACA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AS WELL AS
OAKLAND UNIFIED DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THAT
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ AND
ALSO THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT.
RYAN MACLEAN WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS ALSO SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE MCGANN
WOULD ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS.
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SPECS
ONE OF OUR DISTRICTS HAS JUST
GONE THROUGH THIS PROCESS FOR
THE JUN BALLOT? ON THE CROSS
FIVE DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND THEY
ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS OF OF OF THE
CURRENT REQUIREMENT AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT POSTPONEMENT OF
THIS REQUIREMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
MISTER OBERNOLTE I THINK MISTER
CHAIR IF I COULD JUST BRIEFLY
WERE BUT A COUPLE OF THE POINTS
THAT WERE RAISED.
BOB FIRST OF ALL IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT UNDER THE CURRENT
INTERPRETATION OF AB ONE NINETY
FIVE THAT SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF THE BALLOT LABEL IS DEVOTED
TO THE DISCLOSURE AND I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S E
ACTUALLY THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF
BONDS THAT PASSED LAST YEAR THAT
WERE IN COMPLIANCE THAT THAT.
ARTFULLY CRAFTED IN A.
IF I COULD ALL PASSAGE AROUND
THESE ARE. THIS IS WHAT WAS DONE
LAST YEAR IN FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH AB IN ONE NINETY FIVE AND
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT.
YOU'RE GONNA PULL ON A BOND
MEASURE OF COURSE IT'S GOING TO
PULL BETTER IF YOU TELL PEOPLE
HEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO ISSUE A
BOND TO BUILD A NEW ATHLETIC
COMPLEX FOR OUR COLLEGE. AND YOU
DON'T TELL THEM THAT IT'S GOING
TO RAISE THEIR TAXES OF COURSE
IT'S GONNA PULL BETTER BUT I
THINK WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS. TO BE OPEN
TRANSPARENT AND FAIR WITH THEM
ABOUT THE BENEFIT THAT THEY'RE
GETTING AND WHAT THEY'RE PAYING
FOR IT. AND THAT WAS THE POINT
OF AB ONE NINETY FIVE AND I'M
I'M HIGHLY CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET TO A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION THAT MAKES EVERYONE
HAPPY HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A OF OUR
COLLEAGUE AND I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY IN PART
BECAUSE.-.
THE CONVERSATIONS REMIND ME OF.
A THE THE CONFUSION THAT'S OUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF COUNTIES OUT
MY HOPE IS WE CAN WORK THIS OUT
THROUGH THE PROCESS I AM
CONCERNED THAT IF WE DON'T MOVE
THIS FORWARD. NOW WE WON'T HAVE.
A WAY TO DEAL WITH THIS MORE
QUICKLY SO I WILL SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BUT HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
GET IN CONVERSATION.
THE MOTION I'LL MAKE A MOTION
THEIR SECOND.
REPUBLICAN.
COOPER AYE AYE AERO. CHIU. CHOI.
OBERNOLTE.
YES THE MEADOWLANDS FOR DOCTOR
CHOI.
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
I BELIEVE
.
RETURNING.
GOOD LUCK TO IF THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR FOR ITEMS ONE THROUGH
SIX A THROUGH TEN.
FOURTEEN THROUGH FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN THROUGH NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR.
TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY NINE THIRTY
TWO. AND THIRTY FIVE THROUGH
FORTY.
OKAY.
.
NEXT ITEM IS.
ITEM SEVEN ELEVEN TO THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN TWENTY.
TWENTY THREE THROUGH TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
ONE.
OUT OF TWENTY ONE.
ITEM THIRTY.
NOW VOTING ON THIRTY.
OKAY.
I AM THIRTY THREE.
OUT OF FORTY ONE
.
AND THAT WAS ON FORTY ONE FORTY
ONE.
AND THEN THIRTY FOUR.
THAT'S A NO OF THIRTY FOUR.
OKAY THAT'S IT THANK YOU.
WHO'S OUR HEARING